danach wird es nun bei den taten und
könntet ihr wissen bereit sei geplant
gewesen musste wieder juli wird das
dritte video zu dem glück sei der damen
und herren das erste video 200 millionen
aufrufe bekommen das zweite video hat
auch schon eine million aufrufe meine
damen und herren sind bei den ersten
video haben wir einfach nur doofe
challenges genommen die man eben die
machen musste die beispielsweise beim
roten flecken oder verschiedene andere
dinge eine zweiten video haben wir dann
unangenehme fragen genommen habe ich ein
tattoo das interessante frage an diesem
teil werden wir hälfte coole challenges
und hälfte schlechte challenges machen
das heißt ja bereits der zweite titel
sachen die kursrisiken gute bestrafung
allerdings hat das auch etwas mit low
ablenken als negativ ist dann haben wir
als mutiges team an bekommen dann wäre
native dass man ein bild auf dem handy
zeigen mussten damit die als man bekommt
fünf euro geschenkt hat wir haben
verschiedene gute und schlechte zähne
vorbereitet ich natürlich mal wieder
hinter der kamera
hallo obwohl wir nicht eingegangen
man weiß wie gut die hälfte schlecht du
musst deinen
ich möchte den kleinen tricks bitte was
doch die mutter weiter
[Musik]
sind stärker als zwei lieblinge können
wir durch meine damen und herren das ist
für mich hier zu sehen und eventcenter
die mit euro jetzt suchen ja dann sollte
geld leihen
julia hat der herbst vorgeschlagen dass
wir jeder zu beginn des videos 250 in
eine schale irgendwann bekommt ja dass
sie bekommt alles weil du keine lust
wieder angetreten
das habe ich nicht so ein schwimmbad
passage die tipps gibt zu drei teile
weiter
[Musik]
zu behindern
warum hat früher immer gesagt keine gute
idee eine ewigkeit später dafür mit dem
erfahre freunde das heißt natürlich wenn
ich jetzt hier gibt mehr negative dinge
die nicht passen muss total aber das hat
mir schon ich hätte jetzt auch ein
liebling sind die kirchen gegen die
mittel müssten
[Musik]
wer wird es nur dieses gestellt wir
wollten eigentlich richtig wider so
dieser branche nimmt lief bestellen das
sind die kaller galten zu grünes
mitglied und so die schmecken alle nur
gesund aber die orangen in diesem
gesunden schmeckt auch noch gut und ich
wollte richtig viele von smoothies
bestellt und so kleine aber die hat nur
noch einen
und wenn man jetzt alles positive sache
gesagt derjenige der das kriegt auf dem
glücksrad auf den trinken
der einzige orangen das sind fehler
gemacht so viele kündigt jetzt gehabt
nicht mehr jemand bestellen und möchte
zudem grünes modell
der zvei die challenge of dirt 3 euro
die mannschaft ist richtig mehr hätte
mutti ist auf jeden fall auch freunde
der 19 mit dem geld soll das ist weder
von der story gewesen dass wir deswegen
sei aufgefallen weil er kurz verstehen
aber es geht hier darum dass die person
wie das krieg eigentlich jule aber ich
habe es gesagt wichtig
den braucht da ich jetzt wo sie auch
aixtron habe mache ich das jetzt wieder
das porsche management ist es mandarine
mäßig gefüllt indem ich bislang an
weihnachten
was uns dabei gedacht haben war einfach
dass ich jetzt eine grimasse machen muss
und die kann jeder der hier gerade
zukunft nicht einfach stream schotten
und damit irgendwie dumm - machen oder
keine ahnung was das könnt ihr euch
jetzt eine ausstellung ins damit machen
die macht jetzt auch welche freunde
einig wie gesagt wenn ich dein tier dann
hat das natürlich übernommen
als nichts okay es ist eigentlich genau
darauf aber es ist schon er also der
fall zeigt ihr drauf wir haben hier das
wort liebe freunde das heißt ich muss
jetzt meine turk skills unter beweis
stellt das machst du so ich nehme dir
eine negative sachen abhalten
[Musik]
wirklich mal ganz gut gegen dimitri
nerven ist er die macht das denn diese
ganzen leute in so rap video diese
ganzen frauen einer der maschinen fetten
arsch schriftlich auch schon
überproportional lücken wie folgt ab
[Musik]
julia hatte schnuppert man allerdings
das natürlich nicht auf mich gezogen und
dann das nächste was ich hab ich schon
das sehe ich bei diesen schokolade essen
bringen das hatte hewlett ausgedacht als
gute sache weil sie darauf gekommen
selektiert in den leere packungen
spielte sich viel selber gar kein
riesiger schokolade fällen also ich
werde gar nicht geplant dass ich hier
anfangen solche feinheiten des chips und
was alles aber was haben wir denn hier
das ist völlig man die schokolade kommt
also brauche ich wenn ich schaue sehe
ich so wenn deine lippen geht mit
schnurrbart deshalb trocken das ist auch
nur das ist die welt von mario kurzem
auch durch die stetige freunde das heißt
es geht es für dich ihre angebote
kriegst haare hat das wird jetzt wieder
so lange dauern bis wir das kriegen
okay das ist geil also ich hab jetzt den
jogger das find ich theoretisch wenn ich
dran wenn irgendwas schlechtes über
seine crew ablenken
dann darf ich das wieder abgeben das ist
aber eigentlich mehr als fair weil ich
die grimasse schon auf mich genommen
habe vom bier zahl und dann muss man das
bild auf dem iphone sein da habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich jetzt über eine zahl
sagen muss und sie muss von oben oder
von
das darf ich mir aussuchen irgendeiner
die zahl hoch gehen oder runter gehen
muss das bild hier öffentlich direkt
zeigen also ich möchte dass du von ganz
oben runter geht 25 bilder drauf geht
dann ist das wie die vision streichen
minuten kostete 33 17 18 19 20
eine minute clegg haben wir irgendwie
ein bisschen fälle die kräfte also
bisher juli werden denn du ziehst dich
sehr zurück bei der challenge gerade die
masse abgegeben
keine 20 sekunden gemacht warum hätte
voll professionell verschärft
neulich erzählt die story posten das
jetzt gedacht dass sie wieder einfach
hinten dumme ist sie von sich selbst
machen muss und das sind ihre instagram
story passt schon
wir konnten stadtbild in der story haben
jetzt also auch wenn ich meine damen und
herren wir haben tatsächlich noch mal
überhaupt
wir haben nur noch kollegen übrig mario
mussten das chlor abdecken
mein liebstes klappt da sind so richtig
ekelhaft flecken drauf
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jetzt schmeckt nach putzmittel spitze
also anders erleben wir heute wieder zu
den komment meine damen und herren sehr
sehr sehr sehr viele leute wollen dass
wir eine dritte glücksrad ständig machen
mit positiven und negativem scheint wenn
die glocke das eventuell nochmal einen
vierten teil machen mit dingen die ihr
uns wieder die kommentar ist vielleicht
auch mal dass ich das mit einem anderen
youtube an dann mit ekligen essen sachen
mache oder so schreibt geben wenn die
kommentare lassen einen seite weil ich
das video hier gefallen hat jude ist
definitiv nicht in der beschreibung
verlinken
[Musik]
zum 1